what's up guys it's Marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with a quick video
more of a rant but still a quick video
this is about the HP 85 60 W now this is
not only about this particular HP but it
covers well fat laptops in general oh
yeah
we are going there look there's a weight
limit to what you can call a laptop like
something you would actually put in your
lap let's say six pounds that's more
than the weight of a normal brick if
your laptop weighs less than six pounds
you know that's fair it's a laptop if
your laptop is a fatty like this one
this means it's meant to be a mobile
workstation and look HP even realizes
that you can see it on the branding on
the back side but if you're going to
market something as a mobile desktop it
has to have the performance to match
this laptop has pretty good specs the
quad core i7 processor the eight gigs of
ddr3 ram the Quadro mm graphics card you
know it performs well it took passes all
my tests but the two critical things
that hold it back from being a true
desktop replacement one it has a hard
drive the Windows Experience Index shows
that's what's called a bottleneck it is
by far the slowest part of this would be
desktop computer and to the screen this
one's rocking a 1600 by 900 panel which
is a pathetic resolution there are
literally 13-inch notebooks with a
higher resolution screen than this
laptop the slow hard drive might I add
also makes for a pretty weak battery
life which is kind of inconvenient even
though it's usually at your desk so
basically the point is this if you're
going to make a gigantic desktop
replacement laptop it better have all
the features a desktop would check it
out the G screen space book excellent
specs and dual 17 inch 1080p Plus
monitors or check out the MacBook Pro
more great specs and a very high
resolution display in the end do you
agree
shouldn't those hunks stand on your desk
top be as close to desktops as possible
what laptop do you have a thin enlight
or a desktop replacement if it's a
desktop tell us about it in the comment
section below
mkbhd signing out
this
[Music]
you